voilà on va parler de tirs subaquatique
oui avec donc sylvain bonsoir à vous
vous êtes présents sur ce plateau parce
que ce week-end la palme plaisir oise
organise son traditionnel trophée le
trophée 500 ce qui est une manche de
coupe de france de tir subaquatique
occasion un peu de découvrir cette
discipline qui est un petit peu méconnu
faut faut l'avouer
expliquez-nous un peu en quoi ça
consiste le tir subaquatique les grands
principes
en fait c'est une discipline qui a été
créée par les pêcheurs sous marin dans
les années 70 et qui leur servait de
l'entraînement hivernal donc au fur et à
mesure des années les 10 des épreuves se
sont développées et maintenant c'est une
discipline à part entière est alors au
sein du tiers subaquatique je crois
qu'il ya il ya plusieurs disciplines
dont il ya ce qu'on appelle le biathlon
le super biathlon l'épreuve de précision
etc
plusieurs y applaudir quatre épreuves
qui vont de la moins physique qui est la
précision qui ne nécessite pas de
capacités physiques et qui monte
crescendo physiquement avec le biathlon
et le super bien et le relais également
alors vous dites biathlon on a
l'habitude d'entendre bientôt sur la
neige pour le biathlon nordique
la cc c'est un peu le même esprit il ya
deux de deux épreuves en une c'est ça
s'apparente au biathlon mardyck dans le
sens où il ya une
comment rendre aux mains de la
concentration pour le tir et derrière il
ya une preuve physique qui fait monter
le coeur cette épreuve physique s'est
désolé en hauteur en apnée on a un
parcours on est à 15 mètres de la cible
et ont fait l'aller retour sous l'eau
donc on fait 15 mai on apprenait on
effectue un tir et l'on revient et alors
les qualités pour être un bon tireur
quelles sont elles beaucoup de
concentration j'imagine parce que faire
la distance en apnée puis ensuite rester
en apnée
voilà un avis et ça devrait être une
concentration et puis également une
bonne aquacité savoir bien se déplacer
sous l'eau pour en revenir au trophée
cinq sens ce trophée donc une manche de
la coupe de france c'est ça c'est une
étape importante de la coupe de france
le trophée un plaisir c'est une étape
importante c1 c'est une ré un rituel
tous les ans il ya beaucoup de
compétiteurs qui viennent de toute la
france cette année encore accueillir des
normands des bretons et des lyonnais
donc beaucoup de monde se déplace pour
cette manche oui et pour se maintenir au
sol comment font les tireurs parce que
et cia même la fameuse poussée
d'archimède
oui ça doit être plutôt compliqué de
rester bien bien en bas de la piscine à
l'école et poids c'est presque ça on a
des points
bravo et free on a des fois qu'on
appelle des gueuses donc qu'ils sont
c'est un poids en plomb avec une poignée
qui nous permettent de nous maintenir
que d'une main la main qui tient un
fusil ne se maintient à rien du tout
mais on va s'accrocher à ce poids là
c'est voilà l'esprit quand vous plongez
compliqué quelques tireurs se l'est mais
pas tous donc ça veut dire que vous
tirez avec une seule à la carabine tout
à fait dans cette zone nous aident à
maintenir le fusil en sustentation et ça
suffit pour pour tirer et justement
faisait du tir déjà mais pas dans l'eau
ça vous est déjà arrivé pour pouvoir
comparer les deux oui pendant les stages
équipe de france justement on fait des
disciplines comme ça pour pour faire des
parallèles donc on a déjà fait du bio
périodiques et on a fait aussi du tir à
la carabine du tir au pistolet et puis
les systèmes de visée c'est dans l'eau
ou en dehors le plus dur le tir au
pistolet est assez difficile parce qu'on
est à bout de bras et
dans l'eau on a les mouvements de l'eau
les courants toutes ces choses là mais
c'est vrai qu'un bout de bras on a vite
tendance à fatiguer à bouger j'allais
vous demandez dans l'eau avec les
courants les petites vagues des palmes
des adversaires ça doit être aussi
compliqué pour bien bien se caler sur la
cible c'est des facteurs perturbants
qu'il faut qu'il faut arriver à prendre
en compte est anticipée et pour pour la
palme plaisir oise
il ya à peu près combien de pratiquants
réguliers c'est des compétiteurs d'aider
l'association loisirs la section tir sur
cible n'a pas le mont et 10 10
compétiteurs
quasiment toutes les personnes qui font
du tir à la pomme font de la compétition
avec des niveaux différents de très haut
à des niveaux plus modestes qui viennent
de débuter mais qui sont très motivés
quand on parlait de tir tout à l'heure
en rente n vous me disiez que beaucoup
de pratiquants venait de
la chasse sous-marine à la base oui
c'est ça se rejoint beaucoup les ces
deux sports basse et les pêcheurs sous
marins qui ont créé cette discipline à
la base et donc c'était leur
entraînement hivernal pour eux et
aujourd'hui je dirais que 70% des
tireurs sont des pêcheurs sous marin mai
on a aussi des personnes qui viennent de
divers horizons comme du tir à l'arc ou
du tir au pistolet ou à la carabine qui
pratiquant la plongée associe les deux
et ce week-end l'épreuve de coupe de
france ça va regrouper les meilleurs de
l'hexagone c'est ça il y aura quelques
membres de l'équipe de france qui seront
là oui et vous je crois que vous
participez aussi en outre les le trophée
cinq sens mais à des compétitions
internationales qui commencent à voir le
jour dans la discipline voilà enfin fait
je fais partie de l'équipe de france et
donc j'ai fait une compétition
internationale en italie au mois de juin
et là on en organise une fin novembre à
lyon donc dans laquelle il y aura on
reçoit les ukrainiens les grecs eux les
italiens les russes est votre objectif
sur ce rendez-vous pour l'instant c'est
une rencontre c'est un open donc c'est
une rencontre sans titre définitif mais
l'objectif c'est de des ventes au monde
c'est un bon objectif effectivement
merci beaucoup
si loin d'être d'être venu sur six jours
de téléphiles ce soir et puis donc
rendez vous dimanche pour le pour le
trophée 500 dimanche veut